[Applause]
[Music]
this week's new releases are all
dropping on Valentine's Day so hopefully
your significant other is down for some
medieval warfare and Nazi sniping yeah
romance but if you hit that subscribe
button you'll be the first to see if
next week's games or any lovelier let's
get to it if Knights Vikings in samurai
ever fought what would that war be like
for honor is the answer the unique
combat system forces you to attack or
block in a specific direction so it's
all about faking out your opponent and
striking first and with different
classes in each faction you have plenty
of options to attack 1v1 clashes are
intense but matches also involved
capturing objectives and fighting off
minions in the middle of the battlefield
you can declare war on ps4 xbox one and
pc on Valentine's Day februari 14 and if
you want to get psyched for battle ahead
of time check out our prepare for glory
series featuring the game's different
factions if you want a less bloody
multiplayer game then check out the
former's up to eat players can play as
cute little blobs that take out each
other by shooting ramming or pushing
blobs off cliffs power-ups can totally
change the battle by buffing your blobs
or giving them a big energy blast attack
and don't think the arenas are simple
either the terrain isn't always level
and the whole stage can tilt around
causing your blobs to roll downhill the
cute little guys of deformers make their
way to ps4 xbox one and pc on the 14 and
the violence keeps going Sniper Elite
Four continues the series tradition of
sniping Nazis in the face growing body
and anywhere else you can aim your
Springfield and for the first time fan
favorite x-ray kills also come into play
when you kill a soldier with melee or
stealth you also have more options to
take on the game's new maps across Italy
shoot the high-ranking officers early
and their soldiers may retreat save them
for last and the level will get harder
as you go whichever target you choose
you can
take aim on ps4 xbox one and pc on the
14th if you want to trade your rifle for
a motorbike then ride two is right up
your alley the simulation racer is back
with over 200 licensed bikes but you can
also totally customize your own personal
ride with more than a thousand different
parts you can cruise through 12
different race modes across 30 real
world tracks like the classic
Nurburgring and like plenty of other
releases this week you can take those
races online with up to twelve
contenders ride to roars onto the track
on ps4 and Xbox one on the fourteenth
and finally what's a week of releases
without at least one puzzle game semi
spheres requires you to think parallel
you guide to separate spheres on either
side of the screen solving puzzles means
jumping between the two halves and
uniting them the game includes over 50
puzzles and as you'd expect they get
harder and harder with portals and
teleporting and side swapping coming
into play don't forget about those
patrolling centuries either semi spheres
comes to ps4 xbox one and pc on the
fourteenth and those are the hottest
games will be playing with our
Valentine's this week as always remember
that release dates are based on retailer
listings and are subject to change
thanks for watching guys I'll see you
next week
[Music]
you